[Music]
on this Monday night a Complete Siege of
Gaza Israel's
retribution a bombardment the
Palestinian territory has never seen
before also tonight the threats by Hamas
to execute hostages the largest and most
significant hostage Siege in the history
of Modern Warfare plus the Canadian
killed in the conflict and the others
held captive earthquake anguish
the desperate search for survivors after
Afghanistan's deadliest quake in
years wage Gap win economics is about
people it's about inequality it's about
the female labor force the recognition
and big reward for this Harvard
professor's groundbreaking work
examining
inequality global national with Donna
Fen reporting tonight far Nasser good
evening to you thanks for joining us
Gaza one of the most densely populated
places in the world is being pummeled by
one of Israel's heaviest bombardments
ever the Palestinian territory has been
cut off from Power food and water as
Israel declares a Complete Siege of the
already scarred sliver of land Israel
has vowed to use enormous Force to wipe
out
Hamas there have been hundreds of air
strikes like this reducing row of
buildings into Rubble unlike Israel the
Gaza Strip has no air raid sirens or
bomb shelters Israeli media says more
than 900 people have been killed there
since Saturday's surprise Dawn attack by
Hamas militants gaza's Health Ministry
says more than 680 people have been
killed tonight our reporters are
standing by with the latest on the
escalating conflict from Israel Lebanon
the UK the US and here in Canada we
begin with Jeff simple in Jerusalem
tonight Jeff what's the latest on on the
ground right
now Farah Israel's military says it has
regained control of its Southern
territory where it had been battling
Hamas gunmen for two days Israel has now
called up a record 300,000 reservists as
it turns from defense to
offense Gaza is under
siege Israeli Rockets rain down on the
Palestinian City bringing death and
destruction rescue crews loaded body
bags onto trucks this one containing 14
members of the same
[Applause]
family the shalak family has been
entirely wiped out he says Israeli
forces are attacking us without warning
yes it is a genocide this Palestinian in
Gaza says his neighbors were killed in a
strike their local Market was also
destroyed tar everything
without ask or giving you hear now there
is a bombing Hamas warned if Israel
continues to Target Gaza civilians the
militants will execute their Israel
civilian hostages as part of its weekend
attack Hamas claims to have captured
more than 100 hostages thought to be
among the Hamas prisoners are these
three Canadians including Vivien silver
she spent her adult life fighting for
Palestinian rights she believed in h
peace and Reconciliation and um making
the world the better place Vivian's son
says she grew up in Winnipeg before
moving to Israel in the 70s she launched
and ran various Aid organizations in the
region she organized this March in the
West Bank in 2017 condemning an earlier
Israeli attack on Gaza civilians we must
change the Paradigm that we have been
taught for seven decades now where we've
been told that only war will bring peace
we don't believe that anymore it's been
proven that it's no TR it's not true her
former colleague says she would often
Drive sick Palestinians from Gaza to
Israeli hospitals she's now a hostage of
a group that claims to be fighting for
Gaza this is almost surreal to think
that someone who dedicated their entire
life to building peace ending the
occupation lifting the siege of Gaza uh
is
kidnapped Vivian's home community near
the Gaza border was one of the first to
be attacked by Hamas hiding in her home
she called her son in Tel Aviv we heard
on the phone
screaming yelling and gunshots outside
the window so we stopped uh talking so
they won't hear her so we we continued
corresponding in uh through WhatsApp
up um up until the point she wrote me
that they're inside the
house
um and that was it obviously we can't
speak to Vivien right now but what do
you think her message would be at this
moment it's a good question I'm sure
that deep inside her despite all the
this
difficulties she knows how to separate
between the terrorists and the ordinary
people those Ordinary People of course
are reference to the 2 million civilians
who live in Gaza many of whom aren't
sure if they'll make it through the
night Farah Jeff simple in Jerusalem
tonight thank you
Jeff children in the playground of this
un School in Gaza are pointing to an
Israeli aircraft in the sky as Jeff
mentioned more than 2 million people
live in the narrow strip of land which
backs on to the Mediterranean Sea wedged
between Israel and Egypt and half of
them are under the age of 19 it is one
of the world's most densely populated
and impoverished strips of land in the
world also inside Gaza more than 100
hostages in the hands of Hamas that's
according to Israel and it has vowed to
free them all Middle Eastern Nations
have offered to mediate a prisoner swap
but if Israel decides to use Force to
rescue those in captivity it could be
extremely difficult ult and extremely
dangerous Redmond Shannon looks into
that one of the most haunting scenes to
emerge from the Hass attack on Israel
was the kidnapping of this couple
footage of the captured woman Noah
aramani has since emerged but the fate
of so many other hostages is unknown as
many Israeli and other of different
nationalities are held hostage we are
committed to bring them back how and
when Israel attempts that is key the
armed wing of Hamas is threatening to
start killing hostages if more gazan
civilians die in air strikes Hamas also
claims four hostages have died from
Israeli missiles hitting Gaza katar and
reportedly Egypt are involved in talks
to mediate for a prisoner exchange but
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu will not want to be seen to
make any concessions something of the
scale and this type has simply never
happened before so we cannot look at any
kind of precedent and try to evaluate or
assess what Israel's response could be
there definitely will be significant
pressure on Netanyahu to take a hard
line as Israel mobilizes 300,000
reservists a ground operation into Gaza
seems likely and I think what you're
going to see here is a multi-layered a
multi-pronged approach which is going to
create a massive smoke screen for the
smaller more specialized intelligence
and hostage rescue assets Canadian Aaron
Cohen served with Israel's Special
Operations units what we're seeing here
in my professional opinion is the
largest and most significant hostage
Siege in the history of Modern Warfare
the good news is that
Israel mastered the Playbook Cohen
points to Israel's 1976 raid on anbe
rescuing most of the more than 100
Israeli hostages held in a Ugandan
airport going into Gaza however could be
more difficult the key element is is
getting there undetected and the word
that we use is deception the longer
Israel waits to to conduct those
immediate action hostage rescue raids
the more difficult it is to find them
extracting hostages from densely
populated Gaza would almost certainly
see some civilians killed possibly
hostage casualties too for Israel there
is no good option Redmond Channon Global
News London prent Minister Justin
Trudeau spoke at a solidarity rally in
Ottawa this evening where he reaffirmed
Canada's support for Israel and
condemned any show of support for Hamas
in this country so let me be very
clear Hamas terrorists aren't a
resistance they're not Freedom Fighters
they are terrorists and no one in Canada
should be supporting them much less
celebrating
them we're also learning more tonight
about a Canadian who died in the attacks
and several other Canadians who are
among the missing or captured teria isri
reports when Hamas stormed a music
festival in southern Israel Canadian
Alex look was in the crowd he did not
survive it was hard to believe it just
so
Random a young man attending a concert
somewhere in the desert the Montreal
Jewish learning Center habad Westmount
confirmed his death on social media Alex
was visiting Israel and died in one of
the terrorist attacks as he heroically
and selflessly saved others while
fending off the attackers the
33-year-old montrealer leaves behind a
mother father and sister they're just
devastated
brokenhearted we're trying to give them
that sense of
support more than 260 people who
attended the same music Festival were
also
killed Drone footage shows rows of cars
in the desert abandoned in the Panic to
flee the Ambush was part of a
multi-pronged incursion by Hamas with
Canadians now among the missing and
captive the latest identified as
38-year-old dual citizen Addie vatel
kapon Canada's former Justice Minister
Irwin Cotler tweeted she is an Israeli
Canadian with deep Ottawa roots she was
brutally abducted by Hamas along with
her two children the children were
rescued but AI remains captive it's a
terrible situation and obviously it's a
great concern not only to the Jewish
Community but to the Canadian public as
a
whole pro-israel rallies were held in
cities across Canada we have come
together to express our unwavering
support for
Israel while Pro Palestinian protesters
also gathered where some expressed
support for Hamas what this moment
demonstrates to the world is that we
have the right as a colonized people to
resist in light of the large
demonstrations Toronto police have
increased their presence we want to be
very very clear that we will not
tolerate intimidation harassment or hate
motivated Behavior aimed at specific
communities along with the rallies there
are also vigils planned for the missing
and for Alex look Global News spoke to a
childhood friend who described him as a
kind person who loved to travel and says
his family is now frantically trying to
bring his body back from Israel to
Canada teria isri Global News
Ottawa now to fear is a second front of
the war could intensify at the Lebanese
border our crystal ganing is in Beirut
Crystal what are we hearing from
Lebanese
authorities far lebanon's prime minister
said today that protecting the people
living in the South and ensuring
National Security is the priority but
that he doesn't want Lebanon to be
pulled into the war between Israel and
Hamas Palestinians living here in Beirut
say they're already involved many have
family members in Gaza and they say it's
likely that other Arab Nations will also
join the
fight there's a war on their doorstep
yet there's no fear in the bourel baraji
C camp in southern
Beirut we feel we are very strong badia
alh habit says Palestinians now feel
Victory could be possible against
Israel's powerful Army but it won't be
easy no way it's no way it's a war we
know that israelian army that going to
kill uh many people in Gaza we know they
going to uh punish us but uh we going to
fight they going to release uh the angry
of Palestinian people in Lebanon and
Syria and Egypt and Jordan they going to
H fight all the Palestinian refugees in
the
world the notion of a large regional
conflict involving Nations that have
fought Wars with Israel in the past is
something many people here talk talked
about as I believe 10,000 yemeni
Fighters will join the Syrian front
those who spoke to Global News did not
celebrate the deaths of Israeli
civilians but cited Decades of their own
losses and feelings of being uprooted
from their
Homeland as the poet Muhammad Darwish
said this land cannot accommodate two
identities those identities are buting
up against one
another Israel deployed more troops to
the Lebanese border Monday and again
there were clashes with Hezbollah
Fighters the second day of exchanges in
this area ratcheted up hostilities with
reports of three Hezbollah members being
killed by
Israel heah on Sunday fired at three
Israeli posts on disputed land in what
it termed a show of solidarity with
Hamas lebanon's prime minister has said
that he doesn't want his country engaged
in another war with
Israel as for what Hezbollah has planned
or is willing to do is unclear
especially now that there have been
deaths among its ranks it has the
political power in the country and the
militia is backed by Iran funerals for
those Hezbollah members will be held
here in Beirut tomorrow there's no doubt
it will be emotionally charged and
likely there will be calls for other
Arab Nations to join the fight far
Crystal Gan sing in Beirut Lebanon
tonight thank you
Crystal the UN is warning world peace is
now at risk coming up the worry the
Middle East situation will morph into a
global proxy
war international support has been
pouring in for Israel including military
aid but there are concerns over the
scope of this crisis growing beyond the
region potentially involving other
countries Jackson prco looks at how the
violence may have triggered a global
Chain
Reaction as Israel launches its response
in Gaza the message from allies is
unmistakable we have been focused on
since the minute this broke out is
providing uh support and solidarity uh
between the United States in Israel the
US has dispatched its most advanced
aircraft carrier and fighter jets to the
region and vowed to provide more weapons
Israel reportedly wants more American
precision-guided bombs and interceptors
for its Iron Dome missile defense system
it's all but certain to get them we're
going to want to make sure they don't
get attacked this way again and that
they do what they need to do to pre
preclude that and um so I expect strong
American support for most of what Israel
does over the coming weeks Israel's
allies believe this show of force will
deter a wider War nobody wants this uh
to uh to spill out into other parts of
the region there are no guarantees not
when questions persist about the direct
involvement of outside actors like Iran
clearly Iran has been a supporter of
Hamas it seems to me that Hamas also has
been determined to act as an independent
uh entity the United Nations has warned
more anguish is all but certain and glob
peace is at risk we're now witnessing
another war in the Middle East the
escalation of which will inevitably
cause more suffering to civilians both
Israelis and Palestinians and perhaps
others this also risks becoming another
arm in the proxy war between Russia and
the US with Moscow joining the Arab
League in calls for a peace deal
involving a two-state
solution Ukrainian president President
Vladimir zalinski warned it was in
Russia's interest to inflame tensions in
the region and distract from the war in
Ukraine back in Washington American
support for Israel risks running up
against the realities of domestic
politics there's still no speaker of the
house which could make it difficult if
not impossible for Congress to approve
additional military aid for Israel the
more dire the situation overseas the
more pressure there will be to find a
solution at home far Jackson frco in
Washington thank you
Jackson ahead A desperate search for
survivors what Aid workers say is needed
is the devastation from deadly
earthquakes grows in
[Music]
Afghanistan in Afghanistan Rescuers are
still scrambling to find survivors two
days after major earthquakes left
thousands dead in the Northwestern part
of the country villagers near the city
of harat are using shovels and their
bare hands to search for hundreds that
are still considered missing senior
Taliban officials say at least 2400
people are dead and more than a thousand
are injured and at least 1300 homes have
been destroyed all numbers which are
expected to rise as some of the impacted
Villages were just being reached for the
first time
today there are people sitting there
without shelter they are afraid they are
scared 2/3 of those with severe injuries
who are admitted in the hospital seen
yesterday are children and women so the
burden of this is adding more pressure
on women more adding more pressure on
children who are the most vul vulnerable
groups inside
Afghanistan the first 6.3 magnitude
Quake struck Saturday morning and it was
followed by at least three aftershocks
with a magnitude of 5.5 or above eight
agencies are appealing for international
help as just a handful of countries have
offered public support so far May
neighboring China and Pakistan are among
them next how probing the pay Gap paid
off for this Nobel
[Music]
laurate this year's Nobel economic prize
has been awarded to an American economic
historian for her work on women's
employment and pay economics is about
people it's about inequality it's about
the female labor force
it's about health it's about Economic
Development it's about
wellbeing Claudia golden is only the
third woman to receive the prize and the
first not to share the award with male
colleagues the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences says the 77-year-old was chosen
for her work exposing deeply rooted pay
gaps between men and women the
prestigious award is the last of this
year's crop of Nobel prizes and it comes
with a $1.3 million prize
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm far Asser we leave you
tonight with the grief and despair of
the innocent civilians in Israel and
Gaza as they grapple with the loss of
their loved ones our coverage continues
tomorrow I can't even start to
understand how people think it makes
sense to kidnpped an 85 years old lady
um kidnapped babies kidnapped
[Music]
kids you cannot say nothing
justifies killing Israelis and then
provide justification for killing
Palestinians we are not
subhumans let me repeat we are not
[Music]
subhumans